[Music]
the answer to the question everybody
wants to know LeBron what's your
decision or were eager to
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning
J it's Chinese hero LeBron James I'm
American hero Dave Rubin this is the
reubin report it's December 14th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble locals
and YouTube and we've got a postgame
show as always Ruben report. locals.com
we're also doing a Q&A from our locals
Community today if you want to get
something in on the Fly Brock is sitting
right there he has a computer it's
connected to the internet is that a
hardware connection or a it is there is
some sort of internet going through this
room right now in the air he is able to
receive your messages right now get them
to me on the Fly they can then be put
into Phoenix's computer somehow sent to
the thing that I'm looking at right now
and you could comment to me ask me a
question query me mock me whatever you
want right now Ruben report. locals.com
how do you like my uh I feel like this
is my Easter Sunday Best today you know
what I mean it's really festive just
wrong season but it's all right anyway
the cold open that we did there that was
LeBron James speaking Chinese there is a
reason we threw that to you uh today of
course that was from what about eight
years ago or so when LeBron James uh
left the Cleveland Cavaliers and joined
uh the Miami Heat uh but LeBron James is
back in the news because he is a
hypocrite he is a giant hypocrite he is
a billionaire with a B uh who does not
like America uh and we're going to
connect a guy like LeBron who has become
a billionaire in our capitalist system
playing basketball he's literally living
my dream uh despite the fact that he
doesn't seem to like this place and uh
how many people throughout our
institutions both both cultural sport
political don't seem to like the place
that uh has given them all of the
opportunity that most people could only
dream of also we're going to talk about
California because it's a failed state
but before we get get to all that let's
talk about Cozy Earth guys if you're
racking your brain trying to think of
the right present for someone you'll
never go wrong with gifting the most
comfortable sheets clothing and
accessories that your friends and family
have ever felt I'm talking about Cozy
Earth cozy Earth is just the best their
sheets are soft and it helps me fall
asleep right away you want your loved
ones to feel better sleep better and
smile when they think of you so you
couldn't choose a better gift than cozy
Earth cozy Earth is the softest and most
comfortable sheets blankets towels PJs
joggers and more guaranteed I seriously
love this stuff cozy Earth only sources
premium materials like premium viscous
from bamboo giving the people on your
list a super soft breathable moisture
whisking wicking fabric regulating body
temperature and keeping them comfortable
all day long and all night no matter
what the weather is whether it's their
lifechanging ing luxury pajamas oh so
soft beding loungewear or plush bath
towels you'll love shopping and gift
giving at cozy Earth and here's my gift
to you this holiday season go to Cozy
earth.com enter code Dave to save up to
40 that's right 40% cozy earth.com or
cozy earth.com cve Co earth.com also
guys byy budlight for all your friends
it's a really great beer where's the
check man all right let's get to it so
LeBron James uh went to a basketball
game uh his son is also a basketball
player now his son uh Brock just told me
this right before we started is making
he's he's in college he goes to USC and
he is the highest paid college
basketball player in the country 6.1 mil
a year 6.1 mil a year highest paid
college athlete across Sports LeBron
James son now he's a fine basketball
player that's just fine LeBron went to
one of his basketball games a day or two
ago uh and here's LeBron James walking
in during the national anthem and uh
yeah
[Music]
sitting
sooud
we had the Twilight
last
who
and
[Music]
through
the I mean what is going on here
everyone in that Stadium standing up
hand over heart honoring America as one
should do even if you think she is
imperfect which she is but she's pretty
damn good he just walks in and sits down
and this has been consistent with LeBron
James kneeling for the national anthem
sitting for the national anthem all of
the BLM nonsense um it's not good it's
not good that these people who are
important to us culturally and and at at
a sporting level you know Michael Jordan
who is the true best player in
basketball history no matter what the
LeBron people say Michael Jordan went
out of his way to be a political right
he knew that everybody bought sneakers
everybody watched basketball that you
watch sports and you participate in
sports to get away from the daytoday
nonsense of the world right race
actually has very little to do with
sports these are the people that have
injected it this new generation LeBron
James types right you go to the
basketball court nobody cares what color
you are when you're playing basketball
like can you play if you're good and
you're white they like you if you're bad
and you're black nobody wants you on the
team that's how it works it's the great
equalizer sports but that's what they've
done I should note that I am taking the
team to the Miami Heat game game tonight
and if you guys don't stand for the
national anthem no chicken fingers okay
cuz I've heard the chicken fingers there
are pretty good and I'm not kidding
there will be no chicken fingers for
anybody you stand for the national
anthem uh anyway I want to connect this
to uh the reaction to this sort of thing
because always when these people do
something stupid there's always someone
to respond to it uh a guy by the name of
Colby Covington who's a UFC Legend and
you guys know I always find it
interesting when these people who are
not particularly political they do
something outside of the political all
together they get involved in the
cultural Madness because the cultural
Madness is is just so maddening so this
guy UFC Legend Colby Covington he saw
the video of LeBron James sitting for
the national anthem and he ain't having
it if you hate America so much and and
you don't like this country that gave
you a billion dollars leave it or come
deal with me go to China go to go to the
sweat shops that you employ all these
laborers and use these women and pay
them Pennies on the dollar to make your
Millions F you L drama James you're a
coward you're a spineless coward and
you're a
I want to get that guy on the show
like I don't know any I don't really
care about UFC or anything but anyone
that dresses like that the indoor
sunglasses you're a
can I also tell you something
about LeBron James I'm not a I'm just
not a fan like I'm not a fan I'm not a
fan of the NBA anymore I know there's
this 7 foot five guy you want me to
watch what's his name woma Halo or
something wimy Wim yamba all right I get
it like you know that's fine but like I
just I've just had it with that you know
I watch my old games but LeBron James
I'm playing basketball again even his
sneakers they're too bulky they're just
too bulky get yourself a old-fashioned
pair of Air Jordans you're going to be
happier anyway let's just go a little
further with LeBron because it's just
been endless BS with this guy forever uh
you may remember this this is this is a
couple years ago LeBron James being
asked he's reading the uh he's
apparently reading the autobiography of
Malcolm X
and he was asked what his biggest
takeaway from the book was uh tellor you
want to follow yeah um so you holding
the autobiography of Malcolm X along
with Alex Haley I don't know how far you
are into the book but what's your
biggest takeaway so far um I kind of
just started a couple days ago um but um
I've read and a lot of a lot of notes
over the years this my first time
actually reading this from start to
finish um but just a very
um very smart man very very very smart
man and basically
um his words in the in the 60s and uh
and what was going on is actually what's
going on today
still him understanding the um how
powerful um The Negro can be he use that
word a lot how powerful we are um but we
have to unite
and uh we have to be together we have to
stand strong because there's always
going to be obstacles there's always
going to be um you know things that's
going to be thrown at us where they try
to weaken us um they try to feel make us
feel like we're not kings and queens um
and it's going to come from all you know
different races and different shapes and
sizes and things of that nature
um and um just a very powerful minded uh
gentleman and um and it's it's
unbelievable to to kind of read
something that's coming directly from
him about 10 different jokes that I
could tell you there and most of them
would end my career so I'll just leave
it at um that guy is the Camala Harris
of the NBA what the high held did he say
there no nobody knows it's meaningless
Dil meaningless utter driil and just one
more one more from the meaningless and
utter Dil category here's LeBron
explaining what his favorite scene is
his favorite line favorite scene is from
The Godfather Trilogy it is a question
uh not related to the game but since it
has been a lot of publicity yesterday
and today about Godfather part two which
is the the scene or or the moment or the
phrase or the quote you like more from
the movie oh from The Godfather uh um
it's it's too many different phrases uh
and too many different lines in that
movie to just uh
categorize one
um but quit is the one quit inspirat you
represent you more I mean each movie is
nine hours long I mean what do you want
me to
do I mean there so many I don't know
I'll let you pick one and I roll with it
it's it's a great the horse head in the
bed The Godfather dying at the end the
tomatoes his grandson there's like we
could do a lot here but why do they do
this with everything how about him just
say you know what I actually haven't
seen it or I don't remember they lie
about everything you know it's like that
remember that Obama clip we showed you a
couple months back where that guy on
Comedy Central is asking Obama what his
favorite his wrap-up music for the year
was and Obama lists out a whole bunch of
songs and then he's like could you tell
me one line from one of those songs and
Obama's like oh there's so many lines in
all those songs I can't tell you all
Lebron there's so many these movies are
so long I can't come up with what is
wrong with
people that's the theme of today's show
what is wrong with the people uh anyway
speaking of things and people that are
well speaking of people who have things
wrong with them you guys know that Claud
Dean gay is the president over there at
Harvard at least right now she's now
embroiled in two scandals uh on one hand
she kind of wants people to run around
saying that they can kill all the Jews
and then on the other hand uh it has now
come out that she actually plagiarized
her dissertation which eventually of
course is what led her to becoming the
president of Harvard everyone knows this
now like it's not up for debate on
either front and she's an embarrassment
to Harvard and Harvard has an
institution as I said Let It Burn fine
with me I I don't care but the president
and CEO of the NAACP which is of course
the National Association of Colored
people I think we're allowed to say that
that's
the uh he has defended her and of course
it's well here we go here's the
statement president claudian gay is a
distinguished scholar and Professor with
Decades of service and higher education
the recent attacks on her leadership are
nothing more than political
theatrics advancing a white supremacist
agenda so yes the woman who could not
say weather calling for the genocide of
Jews uh is allowed on campus who now it
is factual she has plagiarized from her
dissertation and you know they're going
to find more where there is smoke there
is fire so if they found it once in a
couple different parts of the
dissertation they're going to find it
and some other things Chris rufo is all
over this uh follow him on Twitter if
you haven't seen more of what he's un
covering over there but of course of
course if you go after her it's because
white supremacy Reigns Supreme it's just
stupid and no one is buying it anymore
speaking of people that no one is buying
anymore Gavin Nome who is the uh
governor of the failed State of
California he went on Seth Meyers late
night show does anyone watch this show
does who watch to Seth Meyer's mother
watch this show nobody watches this
thing but they keep trotting out these
horrible people to tell you that of
course it's the Republicans notably that
guy from Florida who are the real
racists when you started planning this
did you have higher expectations for
where Dan santis would be in the polls
no I didn't I'll be honest with you I've
and and I'm dead serious about this I've
I've developed a lot of animus towards
him because of his animist towards all
of you um you know this guy's out there
scapegoating vulnerable communities uh
he's attacking uh minorities attacking
women and I don't like it and I wanted
to push back against it and I felt like
the party was a little timid on all this
I mean you know he's out there talking
about anti-woke and I mean this it's for
me it's not anti-woke what he really
means is anti-black he's out there
censoring historic facts he's rewriting
history uh he was out there you know he
eliminated AP African-American studies
he said slavery was somehow some
Workforce Development program and he
doubled down on that so for me it's a
very serious moment where I just felt it
was important to blow back against that
against that narrative uh and hold these
guys accountable on a network where they
don't hear from guys like me
ever uh you're on that Network all the
time you're good buddies with Shan
Hannity he says it all the time so
that's a lie of course everything else
he said was a lie we'll just do it quick
is disantis attacking minorities and
women I was at Whole Foods yesterday
almost half the people there were women
I didn't see anyone attacked I saw some
minorities also everybody seemed to be
doing fine buying fruit in the in the
ice cream section everybody was there
it's okay the African-American studies
thing as you guys know that is a
complete lie the curriculum was written
by several black people acknowledging
that some black people might have
learned some skills like becoming a
blacksmith isn't isn't endorsing slavery
it's just actually a fact um and the
reason that they kicked the co the
course out of Florida was because they
combined African American studies with
gender queer stuff and these things have
nothing to do with each other unless
you're in intersectional braet uh but
what's going on over in his uh State
because you know he's always worried
about the the racism and all the evil
stuff Happening Here In The Free State
of Florida uh well in his State uh a
bunch of pramas protesters they shut
down the South 101 freeway through
downtown LA yesterday think we got some
video here so look they just jump on a
highway that is one of the major
highways that goes right through Los
Angeles and look at the cops look at the
cops 10 cop cars right there cops
walking by you don't know if there's
ambulance is there uh there were several
school buses so they're basically
holding children hostage someone's
trying to get home from work it doesn't
even matter what anyone on that road is
trying to do I am of the opinion I
tweeted it out yesterday I have no
problem with police just shooting these
people in the leg and dragging them off
that's it like this cannot stand anymore
we either are a country or we are not
now I get it Los Angeles is a failed
City C is a failed state but for
everyone else out there that lives
somewhere else that hasn't gone down
that road yet you better make sure that
your elected officials are going to do
the right things related to this and
sometimes it can be complex because
there's city state issues there's
Federal highways all of those things but
we better freaking level up because they
are constantly testing us oh we could
send 20 green-haired morons to protest
for Hamas and just shut down highways in
La we can just do that well here's uh
some of the angry drivers uh watch them
removing some of these Pro Hamas people
and I stand with these
people
[Applause]
[Music]
uh I first off I just want to say I will
gladly donate if any of the people that
were trying to remove them are in any
kind of legal trouble now which is
exactly how stupid California is I would
gladly donate to Legal defense funds uh
because they were trying to grab people
off the road so they could either go to
work or visit their mom or whatever it
might be it does not matter societies
either function or they do not note of
course you know they would try to frame
it as they were stopping white supremacy
or something so you know but most of the
people seem to be Latino I saw a couple
Asians out
there go to hell Kevin Newsome that's
the end of the segment uh let me talk to
you guys about Environ CL and then uh
then we'll get to some Community Q&A
guys if all home air purifiers are the
same then why did the US Department of
Defense select enviral cleanse to
protect and purify the air on board our
Navy ships why is it used in thousands
of classrooms across the country well
here's a couple reasons why enviral
cleanses air purifiers have patented
Earth mineral technology and a hospital
grade HEPA filter they also destroy cold
and flu viruses Co allergy inflaming
toxins mold and even more so here's
enviral cleanses promise to you they
guarantee you'll experience far fewer
colds and allergies coupled with a
better sleep at night don't believe them
they'll send you a free air quality
monitor to test the difference in your
home visit EK pure.com use code Dave for
10% off your enviral cleanse home a
purification unit and free air quality
monitor plus free fast shipping that's
$150 in savings EK pure.com code Dave EK
your.com code Dave and now back to me
all right let's dive in Ruben report.
locals.com community Q&A you can get
bonus questions in right now Brock is
monitoring the computer as we speak uh
Margo says hey Dave I heard
psychologists say people can't remember
their childhoods before the age of four
I completely disagree because I
distinctly remember situations when I
was under a year old what is your
earliest childhood memory oo that is a
good one well first off you can
distinctly remember things from before
you were a year I mean that is wild I
guess I guess we all sometimes you can
have like these blips of little images
and things I think about that a lot with
the kids right now like when we're
having fun and we throwing them around
and like they're just having a ball the
idea that they're not going to remember
that but I think I think actually what
gets coded into them is like a feeling
of joy and happiness and silliness and
all that hopefully that is like that's
not a memory but it's like built into
the storage banks that then goes with
them for life my earliest memory so I
was born in Brooklyn 1976 and we moved
to Long Island in about 79 I have a
vague vague recollection of being in our
our apartment in Brooklyn I can sort of
remember a hallway there was kind of
like an orange-ish carpet and I remember
like the kitchen there was no door I
remember the kitchen to the right and I
can't say I remember crawling around on
it but actually my my memory of it is
like kind of low to the ground I really
remember the carpet which makes sense if
you're crawling and you're a kid or
you're you're just starting to walk or
something like it was like a very 70s
like plush Lush carpet kind of thing
that's probably my my earliest memory
but I would be interested to know you
you remember things before one like what
does that even what does that look like
in your brain there are people who say
they remember what it was like to be in
the womb um who the hell knows uh John
says have you seen the trailer for the
new Civil War film and what is your
opinion on it so I had not seen it and
then when we were running through the
show this morning uh we took a look at
it I'm going to throw it to it right now
so this is going to be in theaters I
guess in the next couple weeks right
theater it's going to be in theaters in
a couple month months um but it's
getting a lot of Buzz online right now
so I thought we'd watch it together and
then we can commentates have seceded the
United States Army ramps up activity the
White House issued warnings to the
Western forces as well as the Florida
Alliance the free ter president assures
the uprising will be dealt with swiftly
let me know if you want to try anything
on are you guys aware there's like a
pretty huge civil war going on all
across America we just try to stay out
with what we see on the news seems like
it's for the
best
citizens of America the so-called
Western forces of Texas and
California have suffered a very great
defeat at the hands of the United States
military Mr President do you regret the
use of air strikes against American
citizens are moving into DC today we
need to go down there they shoot
journalists all site in the capital
every Instinct in he says this is death
what but here we are there's some kind
of misunderstanding here Mark we
American
okay okay what kind of American are
you you don't
know
the Western forces will reach the White
House on July 4th oh my god get in the
car get in the
car God Bless
America all right so that's only my
second time watching it I'm sure first
time for many of you guys uh there's a
lot of interesting stuff there I would
say basically you know I like futuristic
kind of dystopian couple years from now
kind of movies uh there is a feeling in
this country that there's a lot of
weirdness between red and blue and
everything else so something seems kind
of cool about it there is a chilling to
it there's there's a warning there's an
uncomfortability there for sure I would
say uh the idea that the Western forces
of Texas and California I mean I'm
pretty sure if we end up in a civil war
situation Texas and California are going
to be on the Rong are going to be on
opposite sides of things right we're
going to have like a Florida Texas
alliance with some other red States
basically with New York somehow and Cali
together and it's just going to be a
geographic mess and all that hopefully
we do not go down that path although you
know me I am for the states doing
whatever is right for the states and for
the citizens of those States um there is
something kind of I would say it's kind
of chilling in I would also say that you
know Hollywood creates a lot of crap
although what do you say a24 as a studio
it's Banger they make bang they make
bangers that means they make good films
told uh so I guess we shall see but you
know what reminds me I'm so I mentioned
yesterday um that I'm watching while I'm
doing cardio right now I'm watching
Leave the World Behind which is on
Netflix it's the Michelle and Barack
Obama produced Netflix show about how
there is a like a digital blackout
everything basically shuts down we
showed you a clip of it I think two days
ago where this the young black girl in
the midst of all the digital shutdown
turns to her dad and she's like when the
world starts up again can we make sure
white people aren't in charge so I was
like you know what let me watch this
freaking thing so I'm about halfway
through I was watching it this morning
there's just so it feels like predictive
programming out of Hollywood they want
us to think the digital shutdown's
coming they want us to think the civil
war is coming one of the things they do
in and Leave the World Behind is all the
Tesla shut down right so they don't like
Elon Musk the Teslas have to shut down
the young girl is very anxiety-ridden
and then there was a even a really weird
line about how so she loves to show
friends and and then this young black
girl is like she likes your your
daughter likes friends like friends is
like a throwback to a time that never
existed like they want to destroy old
things that people love friends and they
want to destroy new things that people
love Teslas like it's just Hollywood is
evil anyway uh Sarah says uh hey Dave
I'm on my own personal Journey trying to
get back in good with God I know that
you have made a similar journey within
the last couple of years I was wondering
what do you think your light bulb moment
was that really pushed you to go back to
your faith thanks for all you do God
bless well I've described it a couple
times I mean about 5 years ago now you
know I do my Off the Grid August thing
and you know usually I catch up on
reading a little bit we've tried to
travel over the years last year last two
years have been trickier with kids and
everything um but you know we'll just
kind of disappear and I'll just sit I
just like sitting on the beach and being
quiet I don't need to do like that month
I I really don't need to do anything I
don't need to go to museums I don't need
to I'm just like I just want to sit and
just Purge
stuff out of my head just escape the
matrix and all that and that that that's
what it is for me and on one year I
think it was if I'm not mistaken it was
2007 no it's probably was probably 2018
2019 I can't remember exactly but I came
back and I was doing the live comeback
show and somebody asked me something
about that and because we did some live
questions and it just became it was just
obvious to me that there there is more
here than just this and I think a lot of
people are coming around to that I think
that that new atheist movement that was
super popular in America about 10 or 15
years ago um I think maybe the idea of a
purely secular world can work when the
system is working but when the system is
not working people need things that are
Eternal I could give you you know 20
lines from Jordan Peterson here um but
for me uh it's been you know we're now
tonight is the eighth night of Hanukkah
so we've lit candles for every night of
Hanukkah um we're try to do Shabbat you
you know it's it's obviously every
Friday I can't say we do it every Friday
but we're trying to do a little more of
that it's about you know connecting with
family knowing what your traditions and
your history are I would also say
relative to me you know since this
October 7th thing I think it's it's
woken up something in a lot of a lot of
people right now um and uh I wish you
good luck on your adventure keep us
posted uh Margaret says hey Dave would
you consider wearing a holiday sweater
one day this month during the people of
the internet show I like that you think
it should not be worn on the Ruben
report we can put it over there I feel
like you have probably like 20 great
ugly sweaters kind of holiday no you
seem like the sweater you you don't
strike me as much of a you don't have a
lot of holiday sweaters you don't you
got one from college you got it like all
right we're going to find something I
will wear something before we shut down
for Christmas I will wear some sort of
holiday sweater uh on people of the
internet Margaret says hey Dave would
you consider oh wait I just did that one
sorry EUR Asian says hey Dave I've been
watching your people of the internet
segments and I must admit that I was
pleasantly surprised how good your
co-host Isabelle is she's really smart
informed and Charming Brock is very
fortunate don't you forget it and she
can keep the conversation going at all
times yesterday was a good example of
this my question is do you think the
fact that we all know you happen to be
gay helps the chemistry between you two
because it comes off as genuine mutual
respect rather than usual older guy
flirting with the young up-and-comer
host um I never really thought about
that but I suppose I I just like her I
think she's great and fun and bright and
I like her
perspective and all of that stuff I
thought she was always flirting with me
you're telling me she's not flirting
with me on that show I thought it was a
lot of flirting with me um yeah you know
sometimes in this right I guess there is
something there right like on a lot of
these shows you get like the older guy
and then the young hot chick and like
there is it's there's this like subtle
sexual tension or something like that um
but to me it's like if you if you are
around people that you like their talent
you think they're good people and
everything else you you'll consistently
bring out the best in each other and I
think that's what we're doing so far uh
cam says Dave appreciate your thoughts
on this scenario the world economic
forum is working on controlling the
globe from every live living angle
economy Health uh travel lifestyle Etc
where do you think they have placed the
Middle East Islam Believers in their
plan I think they have overlook this
little Wrinkle in their takeover plan
that is an interesting interesting
question my guess is that we do not know
all of the plans of the world economic
Forum say the globalist types right we
know certain things you will own nothing
and you will like it they want control
over all of us of how much time we can
spend driving in a car and how many
flights we can take a year and of course
they will do as much as they want it's
just for us the peons I don't know what
the next version of that is now there
there is something sort of interesting
if you want top down control of
something uh there is a connection or or
I'd say there is a
parallel there's a parallel movement
let's say between sort of the globalists
and the islamists right Islam is a is a
totalitarian religion I am not judging
every person who is a Muslim who
believes in those set of beliefs but it
is it is totalitarian in that if you
walk away from it you get a fatwa and
they're going to kill you that's not
great or at least threaten to kilia
right and it's top down right they will
tell you how to behave and that's very
similar to the WF thing so I don't know
could they have some weird Alliance One
Day down the road uh
although you know the the largely
secularist movement which is the
globalist movement how they can deal
with people who are sort of more radical
in their religious beliefs I don't know
but I do think that's partly why right
now they're they're I would say that's
part two or part three of what they're
going for right now they're trying to
take out the judeo-christian world right
they're going after Israel they're going
after the Christian world they're going
after the Western world that represents
the judeo Christian tradition of the
last couple hundred years of of largely
worldwide Freedom when they're done with
that yeah it does seem like they will
have a clash with Islam coming I have no
doubt they've put some thought into that
Joe says which part of the holiday
outfit is more festive a nice red Santa
hat or an ugly
sweater I think people like someone
walks in with the ugly sweater and you
look at them and you're like God bless
you look at you you know what I mean
you're like look at you you really did
it you you just went for it you did it
and you know that the guy in the ugly
sweater it's pretty rare that I think
the guy in the ugly Christmas sweater
walks in and he's not down for a good
time right like that guy's getting drunk
that guy's drinking a lot of eggnog he's
knocking over the tree he's having fun
right he's what's his name cousin uh
what was cousin what's his name in
Christmas Vacation Randy Quaid what the
hell was his name r Cousin Eddie thank
you cousin Eddie Cousin Eddie there you
go
it was Cousin Eddie look at this guy
getting references I can't believe it
Pratt says I'm a Canadian feel sorry for
me okay uh my question is are these
Republicans who are leaving Congress
like McCarthy just rhinos who don't
really care where the US might be headed
with the democrat congress so with
McCarthy stepping down and I think I
mentioned this yesterday there's a guy I
think in Ohio who's about to step down
too to work at a at a local College the
Republican uh majority could be simp as
simple as one vote as one member and you
never know someone falls down the stairs
they break a shoulder sex scandal God
knows what and then before you know it
the Democrats are in charge we have
hakee Jeff as the majority leader and
then the Democrats have the White House
they have the Senate and they have the
Congress and God help us all at that
point you know
McCarthy I think he is I would say
largely uh I want to say bitter he's
he's pissed I I think I can say that he
is pissed about what happened with gay
as I said you know Thomas Massie who's
the most Libertarian member of Congress
nobody doubts that said that this was
the most uh conservative Congress that
he had had in his career massie's been
in in Congress for quite some time so
that they were doing some of those
things now you may be for what Gates did
or not but he I think it's clear
McCarthy was doing some things he wasn't
doing stuff on Ukraine enough I think he
promised to release the January 6 tapes
he didn't fully do that so I'm not
doesn't matter whether you love the guy
or hate the guy you just have to think
for him as a person it's like he's like
you know what I I came in here I did the
best I could you guys took me out and
now he's like you know what I'm going to
go live my life I don't know that I can
fully judge him for that you know like
politics is a freaking messy ass
business and if you can get out of it
with your dignity intact and somewhat
sane and everything else then then
that's almost a miracle so to some
extent just to make sure they could keep
the majority would it be better if he
was there I would say yes on the other
hand just like as a human being like
he's just like man they burned me down
I'm getting out and I'm I'm going to go
get a job and make some money and all
that like I don't know that I can fully
judge him for that Amy says what is your
favorite holiday
cocktail I'm so simple when it comes to
drinks all I just like my tequila on one
rock I am good but let me make it a
little more festive for you uh some kind
of can you throw yeah that that's what I
was thinking can you put tequila in an
egg an eggnog that sounds horrible can
you one of you guys give me a holiday
drink
Margarita a Christmas margarita maybe a
little cinnamon a little grenadine so
it's got some red color we'll throw a
we'll throw a green uh candy cane in
there how about that then you have your
Margarita there you go uh mtra sounds
like a like one of the things that the
Godzilla fought uh says you mentioned an
experimental treatment you use for alipa
can you share what that was uh your bald
chick um so years ago you guys most of
you guys know I had developed alip arot
it was really terrible it was when I was
dealing with a lot of hate online it's
uh it's an autoimmune disease that they
can really only chalk up to stress I
went through all the blood tests and
everything else everything else was fine
they didn't know what what was going on
but people do get this when they're
stressed and I was losing just chunks
and chunks of hair just everywhere all
over my head like quarter size it was
really terrible I went under this
experimental medication which was
horrible it was like this like almost
like this goo like this glue that I
would put on my head and the idea aidea
was that what was happening with with
alopecia is that your white blood cells
start attacking your hair follicles and
they just don't know why so you put this
treatment on and it's basically like
putting poison ivy on your head the hope
is that that your white blood cells
start attacking that instead of
attacking your hair follicles anyway I
had like crazy reactions to that I was
bloated all the time I I was burning hot
all the time I was itchy it was it was
terrible and I was on camera for like a
year like that it was really horrible so
I would I don't even remember what it
was called but I would not remember that
but if you have thinning hair or you're
going through alipa or anything the
thing that I would recommend is PRP
platelet rich plasma they literally
athletes do this if for I do this in my
knee also actually where they take your
blood out they spin it in a centrifuge
and then they get like two vials of your
Plasma in your blood it looks like
almost like it's like goo like sort of
like a yellowish goo and they inject it
back into you so I've done this for my
knee for the torn ACL and then it it
like helps your cells I don't know if
regenerate is the right word but my knee
feels pretty good and I'm playing
basketball again and they can also I've
done it for my hair and they just inject
it back in you and it it helps your hair
get thick and and whatever so uh I would
try platelet rich plasma I'm sure your
your dermatologist knows somebody who
who does it um it's not cheap I do it
like twice a year um and it's I would
say uh that's probably your best bet uh
Mary says Dave do you think your
generation is really finally ready and
fit to be leaders and how would you
change uh sorry and how would you
describe the language that has occurred
in people of your generation that could
convince the older generation that you
can indeed take the Reigns yes the
answer is yes like the the people that
right now I would say are upper 30s that
might be a little bit on the young side
but let's say upper
30s into their late 50s early 60s that's
sort of like a very wide Gen X situation
are ready to go we need a massive
generational shift if you think about
Trump and putting aside all your
whatever your feelings on Trump are and
Biden they both grew up in a world where
they're 80 years old they grew up before
television literally before television
um they grew up in a world of radio just
think about that alone uh that's not to
denigrate them like I can only imagine
when I'm 80 years old what the kid what
my kids are going to be like Dad you
didn't have 3D hologram sex spots when
you were a
kid or whatever like that's you know
like whatever it will be like you know
if you think that when you know when
you're around old people and you're like
you can't believe my God they didn't
have that it was like that when they
were growing up and why do they still
dress like that and that's what they
used to look like and wear and the music
they like just try to imagine in the
accelerated technological time that we
live in now what it's going to be like
when we're old uh but to your point like
Generations have to let go because the
world is changing so fast and it's so
unique right now because of the last two
decades of the internet that the idea
that that Joe Biden who obviously isn't
in charge or even Donald Trump that he
can pave the way for the next four years
so we can get out of some of these
messes I just think is crazy and and
also you know it if you take someone
that say is 45 46 years old and there is
a guy in Florida who's pretty good who's
around that age who has young children
who has to pave the road for his young
children to grow up in a better place I
think there's a more vested interest in
that now Donald Trump has grandchildren
and that's fine but I think it's
different when you're looking at your in
your children children's eyes going damn
I got to get working right now to fix
this thing but it's also just growing up
a little bit differently with the
internet understanding technology under
you know like think how different a kid
who is 15 now who has grown up three
years of crazy coess who grew up with
Tik Tock and iPads and blah blah blah
how how their 15-year-old experience is
so different than my 15-year-old
experience where we didn't have any of
that we had black and white Game Boy if
we were lucky like the world changes
fast and you have and and the point of
the point of having children and
generations going by and by is you hand
off some of that wisdom and then you let
them take the Reigns and the fact that
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and well
Diane Feinstein is gone now but like
that all of these people Mitch McConnell
who's having Strokes on camera and we
just like kind of we're just like all
right let's do it again tomorrow like
even if Gen X was not ready to go which
they are it's it's time it really is
time cat says what was your favorite
book growing up what has become the
boy's favorite book so far the boy's
favorite book definitely is good night
Darth Vader or at least it's my favorite
book reading to them it's I don't know
they never tell me they never they don't
really speak much English yet we're
working on it um but this good night
Darth Vader book it's it's a takeoff of
good night Moon which of course everyone
has and we read that to them as well but
it's it's a really like I got to show it
to you Brock that it's like a really
good take on Star Wars and they use some
stuff from prequels and some from The
Originals and it's like not really
pandering or there's no social justice
in there and General Grievous is in
there that it's just like fun and and
silly and and Luke points to that one a
lot U my favorite book Growing Up by far
by far and this was the first thing that
really got me into reading was The Stand
by Stephen King which I read one summer
I think I was in sleepo Camp probably
sixth grades this is like 1988 something
like that and it was a freaking thick
ass book and I could not put it down and
you know it was funny I got sick at camp
for like a week there was like something
going around uh and I was sick while I
was reading it and if you know the stand
it's about a pandemic and then what
happens in the post-pandemic world and
everything else it's a damn shame you
know then I subsequently read many other
Stephen King books and that that was
really what kind of got me into reading
um but it's a damn shame because Stephen
King he's become such a craz leftist and
on Twitter all day long just like I
don't even follow him anymore but like
one of these people that like man it's
tough to separate the art and the artist
cuz I'm like wow you you are a real
whack job in real life you've created a
lot of great art but it sometimes it can
be hard to separate those things towe
says there's so much there's so much
talk about Donald Trump having a clear
advantage in places like Georgia and
Michigan especially among firsttime
voters both heavily Democrat States is
this actually showing a shift the in the
American voter or is it a tactic being
used by the Press to make Republicans
feel uh make Republicans confident and
feel they don't need to vote and
eventually demoralize them if they don't
win I think there is some level of that
first off you guys know my feelings on
the poll so I don't have to talk about
that but I my sense is it seems so
obvious to me the whole machine is
pushing the hell out of trump and
everyone can have their reasons for
voting him and supporting him and all
that but the whole machine wants him to
be the nominee and that tells you that
he is the one that they think will be
the easiest to beat again when was on
real time two weeks ago every time I
brought up to santis they brought it
back to Trump I was flying home from LA
and I never watch you know I see stupid
little clips of MSNBC but I never have
TV on with MSNBC uh I I post a picture
on Twitter I'm watching the you know the
crack of the seat in front of me the guy
is watching like three it's a six- hour
flight four hours in a row three four
hours in a row of MSNBC it's Trump Trump
trump Trump trump turn on CNN right now
it's most likely Trump why would they
constantly be promoting the guy that
they hate unless they all need him they
need him for clicks and Views and it's
doubly good for them it's not a
double-edged sword it's it's not a
double-edged sword like it's going to
kill you both ways it's a double-edged
sword like it's got two prongs to kill
you it's on one hand it'll get them
clicks and Views and on the other hand
he'll be easiest to beat and I think
that's just a fact and I think that goes
to your theory on on Michigan and some
of these other places
petunia says any chance you will pop up
on Jordan Peterson's tour I just got
tickets to see him and meet uh and the
meet and greet in witcha uh it would be
great to meet both of you that would be
awesome um I have reached out to Jordan
about joining for a couple of those I
have no doubt we'll figure out something
he has it's a limited there's no show in
Miami he's going to a lot of new places
that he has not been before but it is an
American tour uh it's for his new book
which comes out in January it's called
we who wrestle with God I've read I've
read just a little blur that he sent me
so far I think it's going to be really
really spectacular no surprises there um
but yeah he's doing doing a massive I
mean I looked at the dates yesterday and
it's just how many stops is it it's like
it's like yeah it's got to be like 40
stops in like 60 nights the guy is just
an absolute Workhorse and it's just so
good to see him not only feeling great
but just at the top of his intellectual
game and everything else so yes I I hope
to uh open for him and and maybe do a
little something else on stage for at
least uh at least one if not more so
stay tuned on that Elizabeth says how do
you deal with negative press and
comments is it different when it's
random Outlets or accounts versus uh
people you'd consider friends you
know I've been in this game for a long
time now which is very weird but I
started doing the original Ruben report
show on The Young Turks Network in
2013 so we're you know over 10 years
into this thing right now and I've had
phases where you get a lot of love I've
had phases where you get a lot of hate
sometimes you get a mix you know and and
the thing is you cannot pay that much
attention to it so on Twitter like I
just don't look at the mentions anymore
because I could get a thousand people
saying the nicest things to me you're so
great you're just wonderful love your
suit and then you know the thing that
sticks in your head is one guy who says
something horrible or a you know and
also it's been so infected and it's not
just Twitter it's Instagram and all the
things they've been so infected with
Bots there are so many trolls out there
you know one of the ways the trolls are
operating right now which is it's it's
just worth noting um is the trolls they
coordinate on different sides so a lot
of the troll groups they have telegram
channels where if they don't like what
somebody said so if one day they don't
they do this to Ben Shapiro a lot like
these kind of like Neo-Nazi type or
these like gper frog losers what they do
is they take they'll so the Ben will
tweet out something they take the Tweet
they post it in the telegram group and
then they tell everybody okay go attack
that tweet and then the average person
sees that tweet from Ben and they see
thousands of responses saying horrible
things to Ben and then what you're what
the average person might uh ascertained
from that is oh my God Ben is really
hated but it's not really true it's just
that the trolls and the Bots are really
well coordinated there's a generation
that grew up in the internet that that
is very nihilistic in nature and they're
using all of all of the
tools this little device they're using
them to just re uh you know just wreck
so many good things you know it's
another thing about the one one of the
reasons that we shut the comments down
people ask about this a lot we don't
shut
uh right now if you're watching the show
if you're on locals we have our chat in
locals and Brock is in there right now
and and can respond to you guys and give
me ideas and things of that nature and
that's where we get the comments from
and you guys have a little skin in the
game because you put a couple bucks in
every month and you support us and keep
us independent and all that so that's
where I focus most of my energy we also
have the comments on on Rumble because I
believe that Rumble is standing up for
free speech and we're in partnership
with them and everything else we shut
the comments off on YouTube during the
live stream because I want to encourage
people through better Behavior to go to
those other things but you know as a
general rule the comment section it's
really interesting because think about
it if a video our videos have been
getting our live streams have been
getting just unbelievable views the last
couple weeks but let's say a video gets
a million views a million views well 90
I don't know what the exact percentage
is but let's say it's probably about 95%
of people they just watch the video they
don't comment on it they don't thumbs it
up they have their own thoughts maybe
they send it to a friend but their
feelings usually are pretty good which
is why they watch and that's it
generally people who comment not always
our comments actually and when we post
to YouTube after our comments are
usually pretty freaking positive but
generally if you were to look at the
comments it's not that you're getting a
great cross-section of who is watching
the the videos and what they think
you're getting a cross-section of the
types of people that comment I'm not
judging on people that comment I think
it's great to share your thoughts but
everyone should know that it's a it's a
selected group of people so anyway as
per the hate and all that stuff it's
part of the job but I would tell you
that the the rewards of what I'm doing
uh far outweigh that stuff if you have
not subscribed to us on Rumble it's
rumble.com rubben report if you want to
play along and get some questions in
it's Ruben report. locals.com Brock you
want to throw me a question on the fly
right now do you have a question or a
comment you want to throw me at this
very moment I will continue for just a
moment while Brock looks at something uh
if you want to buy some merch for the
holidays Dave ruin. store is there a
thing over here is it somewhere over
here there it is right there you like
that it's right there it's right there
you get a hat you get a hoodie you can
get a mug and more Dave ruin. store uh
we've got a new account on Twitter it's
rubben report show where all the clips
will go up my interview with John chis
we just put up he's a comedian who is
non-woke funny dude enjoyed it uh he's
doing a show in Miami I think I may take
part in that in a couple months we're
going to work on that and I'm uh I think
I've got something from Brock Brock what
do we have question comment what's on
the people's mind Minds right
now we've got one from Phoenix uh I
don't Dr wiery says I don't really get
why Sports has become a vessel of
political positioning I couldn't give
two rips about what they think I'm here
to watch them play
exactly exactly it's as simple as that
like it's not to say they can't say what
they think Everyone's entitled to say
what they think but you better know that
it comes with a cost and if you think as
LeBron James a billionaire in America
playing basketball and now your son is
the highest paid college athlete in the
world and if you think that you're
getting any more fans or doing the right
thing by denigrating the flag and our
country and everything else no
you is that all for
today that's all for today but we do
have a postgame show at Ruben report.
locals.com in just a sec so hang tight
for that everyone else see you tomorrow
thank you for giving me the privilege to
represent our city and our San Francisco
values in the Congress human rights
reproductive Justice lgbtq equality
respect for immigrants and care for each
other our safe communities require gun
violence prevention addressing new
causes of gun and supporting law
enforcement with Justice in police I am
know for the election to Congress and
respectfully seek your
[Music]
support